uh I don't know what to say about this I
I was told that we sold an enormous
amount of these yesterday when I
announced it and I'm deeply disappointed
in all of you I don't I don't want you
to buy this like I'm just telling you
the honest truth I don't please don't
buy this damn thing uh it's not right
it's not okay I was never fully on board
with it and I so don't buy it I'm dead I
make money on these things and I am
telling you don't buy it they've got
this whole copy in front of me they want
me to read I'm not going to read it I am
telling you that we put these on and you
know it was it was kind of a test it was
like how willing are people to to buy
something this this really disturbing
and I had hopes I was uh I like the
small glimmer of optimism that I still
carried with me in my soul I said no
people aren't gonna people aren't gonna
buy that there's uh nobody wants that in
their house what are you gonna do with
that anyway you can go to dailywire.com
shop to get yours today